Bon allez stop on arrête
Quoi ?
On arrête, ça sert à rien !
Ben pourquoi ?
Ben parce que ça marche pas !
ah là, c'est sûr, Il marche pas, là !
Il bouge même pas.
Mais ça va aller, on va y arriver !
Oui mais quand ? On a plus le temps là !  Il nous reste 29 minutes !
On a 29 minutes pour réussir à le faire
marcher, après, c'est foutu !
Bon quelqu'un a une idée ? Hein ?
Euh..... on pourrait euh.... un pied comme ça là....
Ok ! Merci ! Quelqu'un d'autre ?
Des définitions ?
Quoi ? Quelles définitions ?
Ben des définitions sur la marche !
C'est à dire ?
On prend genre un dico quoi, ou on peut aussi
essayer d'imaginer comment définir la marche et puis....
C'est bien ça les définitions ! Allez on y va ! Hop c'est parti
: définitions !
Marcher – Verbe intransitif. Du francique
Markon "marquer, imprimer le pas".
Non.... c'est pas...
1 - Se déplacer par mouvement et appuis successifs
des jambes et des pieds sans quitter le sol.
Pas mal !... Mieux...
2 – Avancer au moyen d'un autre procédé
que la marche normale
Comme ça par exemple ?
Oui comme ça !
J'en ai une !
3 – Aller à pied
Nan nan...
Nan, nan, nan, j'en ai une beaucoup mieux !
4 – Marcher sur ses pattes, sans courir,
ni sauter.
5 – Acquiescer, donner son adhésion.
OUI !
6 – Fonctionner
7 – Poser le pied sur.
Sur quoi ?
Ah je sais !
Marcher, c'est changer la terre là où l'on
est passé.
C'est se déplacer soi-même, sa vie et sa
culture aussi
Attendez, mais la marche c'est aussi une grande course entre la
droite et la gauche, qui pourrait bien durer une éternité.
Oh j'en ai une ! Marcher, c'est le passé, le présent, le
futur. C'est le dépassement de soi-même. C'est être fier de soi, être
triste, ou même en colère.
Oui mais, Marcher, c'est pouvoir oublier qui on est
habituellement, se redécouvrir, se réinventer au
long des chemins.
Marcher, c'est comme éclaircir la planète,
c'est comme revivre.
Marcher c'est la vie !
Mais oui c'est ça !
Il a bougé j'suis sûr !
OK ! Ça veut dire que c'est bon : on est
sur la bonne piste !
Attendez...Alors, la vie la vie la vie.....La vie mais
oui voilà ! c'est ça ! La vie en marchant !
On refait toute notre vie pas à pas, en
marche ! Ok on y vas !
On est quel jour aujourd'hui? Y'a pas un truc aujourd'hui sur le téléviseur?
Mais qu'est-ce que tu dis toi ?
Oh mais c'est l'heure du feuilleton, c'est l'heure du jeu !
Ah les champions, oui
Bonjour Chers Téléspectateurs, et bienvenue
dans votre émission favorite
" La Marche des
Champions ! "
Aujourd'hui, nous accueillons 3 nouveaux
candidates : Et on dit Bonjour à Alphonsette
On dit Bonjour à Georges, qui est podologue, et qui nous vient de Paris !
Et enfin Pascal, votre grand champion de Bretagne !
Alors je vous rappelle les règles très simples, de ce jeu, qui se déroulera en 3 parties.
Dans la première vous devrez reconnaître des expressions illustrées
par nos chères assistantes qu'on applaudit bien fort
Dans la seconde partie il s'agira de retrouver l'auteur des
citations que je vous proposerai
Et
enfin dans la troisième partie, attention, il faudra réaliser une "Silly Walk"
ou "Marche idiote", évaluée à l'applaudimètre,
ce qui vous départagera, enfin.....on l'espère
Des questions ? Non ? Parfait !
Commençons !!!
marcher sur des oeufs ? Marcher en Canard !
Oui! Bravo !
Marcher au pas de l'oie
Oui bravo !
C'est marcher sur un fil
OUI !
Je dirais, euh...Ouvrir et fermer la marche ?
Bravo!
Marche ou crève !
Nan c'est une mauvaise réponse...
Marcher sur des oeufs !
BRAVO !
Nos deux concurrents sont maintenant à égalité et Alphonsette part perdante du jeu
Mais ne vous inquiétez pas, on vous offre un magnifique dictionnaire
Au revoir ! à bientôt !
COUPURE PUB
La Marche c'est le pied !
La marche est une activité naturelle que tout le monde pratique chaque jour.
A un rythme tranquille, on peut marcher à tout âge.
Mais habitués à la voiture et aux transports en commun
nous avons tendance à oublier que la marche peut nous être bénéfique.
Redécouvrez ses bienfaits !
Activité naturelle, elle peut être pratiquée
par tous
(sauf en cas de problèmes de santé aigu).
Nous sommes tous faits pour bouger et la personne qui marche emmagasine immédiatement
une production d'énergie, un meilleur acheminement d'oxygène dans le sang et les muscles et consolide son squelette.
Elle met ainsi en place un programme santé par excellence !
La Marche c'est le pied !
Retour au jeu !
Nous sommes maintenant dans la seconde manche, et attention : les citations !
Première citation : Même quand elle marche on croirait qu'elle danse.
C'est de la poésie !
Euh.. Jacques Prévert ?
Nan ! C'est une mauvaise réponse
Charles Baudelaire !
BRAVO !
Si tu n’arrives pas à penser, marche ; si
tu penses trop, marche; si tu penses mal, marche encore.
Jean Giono
Oui, bravo !
Troisième citation : Chuck Norris ne marche pas, c'est la terre qui défile sous ses pieds
Attention il y a un piège, Chuck Norris ne marche pas, c'est la terre qui défile sous ses pieds
Chuck Norris
Dernière citation, attention
Parce qu'on a créé une réalité et dans
notre réalité, on a inventé le temps: les 24 heures, les 365 jours par an.
Ce qui est bien! Comme ça on sait que quand je traverse le living-room
et que je marche de ma cheminée à ma fenêtre, ça prend 10 secondes
mais pour l'oiseau, ça prend une seconde et pour l'oxygène 0 seconde!
Je suis pas sûr, mais Jean-Claude Van Damme
Nous passons maintenant au Silly walk car vous êtes encore à égalité et Georges vous commencé
Alors je vais vous présenter une marche vraiment ridicule qu'un passant à fait l'autre jour
Vous l'avez compris, Pascal remporte le titre du grand champion de la marche, on peut l'applaudir !
STOP ! Non mais vous faites quoi là ? Une émission télé? C'est bien ça ?
Et c'est censé le faire bouger ? Non mais on marche sur la tête là !
Mais oui c'est vrai, vous vous rendez pas compte, on marche sur la tête là !
Vous avez vu ou on en est ? On est
passés de la marche d'une vie pas à pas,
à une émission Télé comme si de rien n'était !
Et ça choque personne !
Alors je vous propose quelque chose d'un peu plus collectif, quelque chose d'un peu plus fédérateur, vous voyez ?
Ah non justement là on voit pas....
Ok ! toutes les grandes
révolutions dans ce monde, toutes les contestations
et tous les changements importants
sont arrivés parce que des gens se sont levés
et se sont mis à marcher pour la liberté, pour leurs droits ou contre quelque chose d'injuste !
Mais oui c'est ça ! écoutez la !
Et pourquoi à votre avis ?
Parce que les gens se sont mis en mouvement ! Parce qu'ils on fait qu'ensemble ils n'étaient pas seuls à marcher
et qu'ensemble,
ils pouvaient modifier la marche du monde !!!!
OUAIIIIIIIIIIIIIISSSSSSSS !!!
Alors je vous demande à
toutes et à tous, de vous lever et de vous
dresser face à Jean-Kev, et de lui demander
je dirais même mieux d'exiger de lui, qu'il se lève : Jean-Kev ! Lève toi et Marche !!!
OUAIIIIS ! VAS-Y !!! Jean-Kev avec
nous !!!!
MARCHER ! MARCHER ! MARCHER !
MARCHER !
MARCHER, c'est s'ouvrir au monde !
MARCHER, c'est se dépasser pour aller
plus loin !
MARCHER, c'est écraser le sol sans lui
demander !
MARCHER, C'est fendre le vent !
MARCHER, c'est faire tourner la
terre sans s'en rendre compte !
MARCHER, c'est laver le sol avec ses
chaussures !
MARCHER, C'est dire adieu à l'ennui !
MARCHER, c'est pas pédaler !
MARCHER, c'est avancer !
MARCHER, c'est pas courir !
MARCHER, c'est marcher !
MARCHER, ben c'est quoi ? C'EST COOL !!!!!  c'est quoi ? C'EST : COOOOOOOOLL !
Alors ?
Rien
Hein ?
Il a dit quoi ?
Il a dit rien
Il a rien dit ?
Non ! Rien ! J'ai dit rien de rien !
Il bouge pas, pas un mouvement, pas un pas même pas un tout p'tit rien du tout ! Rien ! Pas d'pas !
Pas d'pas ? C'est pas d'pot, quand même......
BON !! On va se reprendre hein ! Allez !
Ben tiens ! On a encore perdu 15 min mais
tout va bien !
ça manque peut-être un peu de démarches
scientifiques tout ça non ?
Ah oui ! Des marches scientifiques, ça va marcher ça !
c'est à dire ?
Et bien, on pourrait faire une étude du
mouvement de la marche, par le biais d'une expérience scientifique
comme la chronophotographie par exemple.
La chrono-quoi ?
Ouiii ! Si si , je me souviens, on a vu ça
en physique avec Mr Aubin :
on décompose le mouvement pour mieux le comprendre.
Si Jean Kev comprend mieux la marche, peut-être qu’il y arrivera mieux !
Ah ouais ! Ça peut bien marcher ça !
Ok ! Va pour la Chronophotographie !
STOOOP ! On arrête ! J'ai la solution ! J'appelle Armel !
Non mais l'autre eh ! Vise la
solution : "J'appelle Armel" !
"J'appelle Armel, la solution à tous vos
problèmes !"
C'est qui Armel ?
C'est un pote à mes parents
Il est quoi ? marcheur ? Spécialiste de la
marche ? Inventeur du pied d'vant l'autre ?
Ah ouai ? Et bien justement ! Rigolez va ! Il est
chercheur en sciences du mouvement !
Quoi , vous voulez une preuve ? Vous voulez que je l'appelle ? Et bien je vais l'appeler alors !
Allo ? Allo Armel ?
Oui C'est moi ! Alors ça va ?
Ben nan justement euh.... ça va pas .... On a un problème !
Ah bon ? C'est quoi ?
Ben c'est JeanKev là, on a un problème avec lui. On a tout essayé.... de la chronophotographie quand même !
La chronophotographie ?
Oui, le truc de Jules-étienne Marey,
avec une photos décomposée avec des mouvements
Oui oui la chronophotographie je connais bien, avec Marey, Muybridge, ok, mais c'est juste que c'est terriblement daté !
Vraiment ?
Ben oui la chronophotographie moderne si tu veux c'est plutôt la motion capture !
L'ammaussion - quoi ?
La capture du mouvement si tu préfères c'est justement ce que je suis entrain de faire !
c'est ce qu'on utilise en sciences, en
recherche pour le mouvement, ce qu'on utilise aussi cinéma pour faire des effets 3D.
Ah oui ! D'accord..... sauf que je vois pas....
Ah ben si vous voulez on va le faire ensemble, on peut le faire maintenant si vous voulez
Vous vous allonger ...ok voilà, comme ça.... vous bougez plus..... je lance la capture....voilà
ok prêts ? Allez Chauffe Marcel ! C'est parti
!
Hey !!! Il s'est mis debout !
Super ! Merci Armel on te rappelle !
Bon il reste combien de temps ?
10 Minutes !
Bon alors vite ! On fait quoi?
Euh.... Maintenant on a fait le plus dur....
Oui mais faut encore le mettre en mouvement
!
Attendez attendez ! Le problème c'est qu'on a tout fait à l'envers !
Comment ça ?
Ben oui : on lui a montré comment
on marchait, nous ! Mais il peut-être lui montrer comment lui marche !
Tu veux dire comme si on était une marionnette ?
C'est ça, exactement !  Comment on marcherait si on nous faisait marcher !
Ok ça se tente ! Toi toi et toi vous vous
laissez faire et vous là, vous les manipulez, ok ?  et moi aussi
Bon là c'est fichu !!!! Il a même pas vraiment fait un pas !!! Les gars !
Mais arrêtes de paniquer, merde !
8 minutes ! Il nous reste
8 minutes purée ! On va pas s'en sortir là !
Ok ! Je sais ! On a rien compris ! L'énigme
qu'on a eu au début c'était bien
"Marche ou crève : vous
avez 33min et 33 secondes" et cette marionnette en carton là
Jean-Kevin en plein milieu ?
Oui et ?
On a donc cru qu'il fallait la faire marcher
pour s'en sortir, c'est bien ça ?
Oui ! Vas-y abrège !
Et bien s'il fallait plutôt Marcher comme
si c'était une question de vie ou de mort ?
Une sorte de marche ou même de course pour la vie, vous voyez ?
Si on s'en foutait de la technique, de la façon de marcher?
SI au final ce qui comptait c'était juste
Marcher ET Vivre,
Marcher POUR Vivre !
Une course pour la vie....
Au ralenti !
Oui comme ça on ralentira le temps et on arrivera jamais à zéro !
Voilà !
Ouais c'est bien ça !
Bon toutes façons on a plus trop le temps
d'essayer autre chose, alors vite.... dépêchons nous
Donc on tente ça, c’est notre dernière chance ! Bon courage à tous ! Et maintenant :
Run for life !